Hey, David, we've seen John Roberts side with
the liberals twice now, once to not end Dacca.
And this week with the liberals on abortion,
is John Roberts actually a moderate justice?
Has he become more moderate?
Beautiful question.
This is really, really important.
We've heard in the wake of these two decisions
from the Supreme Court where John Roberts
was against ending DACA and against requiring
doctors who perform abortions to have admitting
privileges at local hospitals.
And these were decisions where John Roberts
was with the liberals, so to speak.
So I want to look at two things here.
What do these decisions mean about John Roberts
politics?
But first, where is John Roberts politically,
ideologically in terms of justices?
There is a chart that uses a scale of plus
eight, meaning ultra conservative, down to
minus eight, meaning ultra liberal four Supreme
Court justices.
This is something that's done by Roberts and
Quinn.
I'm sorry.
Martin and Quinn on that scale.
John Roberts started his Supreme Court career
at a one point five, meaning on the right,
but not as on the right as Clarence Thomas,
for example, he was a one point five and John
Roberts, based on his decisions, has been
moved down to zero point five.
So he went from one point five to zero point
five zero would be a perfect moderate.
So John Roberts, according to Martin and Quinn,
has moderated since joining the Supreme Court.
OK, for comparison, Clarence Thomas is like
between a three and a four.
Much more conservative.
Samuel Alito has gotten more conservative.
He's gone from a one point five to like more
than a two.
So it does appear as though John Roberts is
certainly more moderate than some of those
other justices.
And John Roberts has moved a little more to
the middle since joining the court.
Here's the real important question, though.
What do these specific decisions mean about
John Roberts ideology?
And it really doesn't mean much.
And here's what I mean by that.
These were mostly technical decisions where
John Roberts was with the liberals.
So on Dacca.
John Roberts didn't weigh in at all on the
merits of DACA or the legality of Dacca in
some broader way.
The Trump administration brought a very bad
case against Dacca.
The case the Trump administration made was
essentially Obama didn't have the authority
to do Dacca.
The court rejected that argument.
The court said, merits aside, Obama did have
the authority to do this.
Roberts sided with the liberal justices there
on a technical matter.
And in fact, it should have been nine zero
like it was such an obvious, easy decision.
This was just a bad technical argument from
the Trump administration.
It should have been nine nothing.
Roberts was with the liberals for technical
reasons.
Similarly, this week in the abortion case
in Louisiana, what the court found in its
majority decision and John Roberts was on
the side with the liberals and wrote the majority
opinion was that if you require abortion,
doctors better, said doctors who perform abortions.
I try to avoid that term.
Abortion doctors, doctors who perform abortions
if you require them to have admitting privileges
at certain hospitals.
You are, in a technical sense, violating Roe
v. Wade, which is precedent.
It's established law.
And for that technical reason, John Roberts
was with the liberals.
It was not about the merits of abortion, the
morality of abortion or anything else.
So the good news is that compared to the real
ideologues, Thomas Cavanagh, Gorsuch, etc.,
John Roberts is not so ideologically biased
that he will even get the technical decisions
wrong.
That's a good thing.
The reality is we still need to do way better
than Roberts and we certainly need to do better
than Gorsuch and Cavenagh.
And that's why one of the important reasons
for removing Donald Trump and putting in Joe
Biden remains choice is to the Supreme Court
and selection's to lower courts as well.
We've got a great Bonas show for you today,
producer Pat.
We'll be taking over the reins.
I will be back with you on Monday.
We are taking Friday off as a sort of extended
Fourth of July holiday.
And then we're back fully full power.
On Monday.
I'll see you then.